the golden san francisco i know i live there
on the tower seagull pigeon but i like it
you can always sell flat fee ace on
every corner i look too hard fellas
they got guns we got a thousand fellas
the king pin this tough sheen the bosses
because the spirits from some honor at night
you can always tell that's the lonely one
some parts of mission you could always tell
a thousand on every corner there was a crime
they'd be right on death row with chestnuts
look out oh man look at old man mike is on
his face head first light up fellas didn't
cost me anything five fingers and a quick
getaway some store supplies yeah on the scene
i am stanley moss attorney general of the
state of california there is no one cause
for juvenile delinquency and therefore there
is no one cure for juvenile delinquency the
elements that go to make up a uh fine young
person in our society are generally threefold
first loving parents secondly intelligent teachers
and thirdly a wholesome environment in which to
grow up but all too many of our young people today
lack one two or even all three of these elements
and therefore we have what we call juvenile
delinquency the community then has an
obligation to provide those missing elements when
i speak of the community i mean society generally
officially and also private organizations which
work in this field any private organization
that gives to youngsters the opportunity to do
something useful and constructive gives them a
chance then of belonging of participating
of winning the approval and approbation of
their elders and of their contemporaries any such
organization in our society today is doing a most
useful and constructive thing both for the young
people and for the community in which they live
ain't that sweet
we'll show you how it's gone
always ain't that
we cold you a little sample he looked
like elvis before he went to service
there's a couple of my good
friends they're squares
looks like the fight of patterson engelmar
but it's not left to the right left to the
jaw right to the chin feet to the chest knife in
his back brass knuckle on his head someone who's
on the ground someone's on the ground i think
it's the referee no it's not it's an officer
don't get panicked ladies don't get panicked
ladies nothing will happen it's only in fun
look out keep it clean keep
it clean with energy no beats
what no job but don't worry i know what they'll
tell you you're too young you're unexperienced
you're not in the union we can't
bond you you've been in trouble
you're not a graduate we can't use you but don't
worry don't worry old lady loser christmas money
purse will be snatched some more man will be
knocked down and everybody will wonder why
people but if they don't see you fight it's
hearsay that so they believe it because you're
in a club and you wearing a club jacket so
you're a thug right away to the public then
you know what but it's some people that realize
that uh you know that by being in a club
but it but it can be a good thing and a club can
be a bad thing yeah but yeah but you have to start
off with the right thing to end up right when carl
may started youth for service he realized he could
work through the leaders of the jacket clubs at
first i went out and looked up these boys on the
street this is john bird president of the warlords
a very important club in san francisco i just
put it up to them would they help i told them we
needed them and it worked because it was the truth
well gentlemen i'm carl may i'm with the
organization you ever heard youth for service
you know this is the organization
with all the clubs in it you know the
warlords and sheiks and the turbines
the timers the aces and the ravens
oh is this uh constantly that's all the clubs
yeah that's it we'd like to have you guys in
and one of the reasons that we started
the council and started youth for service
is to help out people old people sick people
handicapped people go in there and do paint
painting jobs for them or carpenter work and
clean up their places when they need help
and we've got a uh we've got a family now
that needs some help and um we want to go
there next week next saturday so well
what do you say yeah what are we doing
will you guys go oh it's over on um hill
well i'll tell you we'll pick you up in the
morning this is a youth for service work project
these boys are working for nothing doing something
for somebody else who needs help why are they
doing it the answer is that these boys are no
different than the rest of us they need to be
needed they may have had less chance than most
of us to relate constructively to the community
they need the opportunity to work for status and
recognition in youth for service we take them
as they come we do not judge them for anything
they may have done or failed to do in the past
we do not excommunicate them if they fail to live
up to our standards of work or conduct what we do
is accept them as individuals and put them to
work we ask them for help and who can resist them
oh
god
another project built a new
parking area for a community center
youth for service is not a training program
for future employment but it does give the
opportunity to learn something of new
skills work projects are referred from
many sources chiefly from social agencies
the departments of public health and public
welfare the visiting nurses association
the family service society and others
the entire youth for service program has been
made possible through generous health from church
groups businessmen school and civic authorities
and private as well as public agencies
the boys of youth for service
have helped many elderly and
handicapped people with home chores and
repairs they cannot manage themselves
when this project started i figured that if
what i believe is true then people who have
known bitterness and despair and frustration
will have every bit as much human understanding
as the most enlightened people the supposedly
enlightened people that there were around
is many spanish-speaking people live
here in alviso near san jose a youth
for service project helped finish a classroom
in the church to be used for english classes
sure the boys mess up on a lot of
things when they're on their own
but they get something done and what they do
is their achievement they can learn from it
and be proud of it adult control or adult
guidance really means the imposition of authority
and that would kill the whole idea the boys
know that this is their program and that it's
in their hands not ours they respond to that
you know you can ask a person to do something
and you'll see a difference in the work because
if you ask me to do it i'll do a better job
i'll do anything if somebody asks me but if you
say do this do that if you don't do it well you
better do it well i just won't do it and i want to
see what somebody's going to do if i don't do it
the boys of youth for service
give of their strength and time
and skill and the community gives too and
both get back more than they give a sense
of sharing and the boys get something they
greatly need tangible evidence of community
confidence in them expressed in terms of good
materials and efficient and valuable equipment
and a good lunch on the job is a pretty
well understood form of moral support also
the word is recognition the boys of
youth for service work hard without pay
most of them have very little themselves yet
they volunteer repeatedly to help other people
in need recognition and community
support become very important to
maintain morale a little publicity for work
well done is small payment by the community
for services generously given a party was
organized to celebrate the first hundred
work projects completed in spite of some
initial opposition concerning law and order
the party did go off quite smoothly after all
enjoyed by several hundred youth for
service participants and their dates
only one slight mishap was reported
a policeman somehow lost his badge
a council of youth clubs from all parts of
the city developed directly from the contacts
made on work projects the boys themselves
decided they wanted a common meeting ground
where they could adjust differences between
the clubs before they blow up into rumbles
they also wanted to promote social affairs
and special projects on a citywide basis
both and security were involved
in belonging to the organization
one of the first council projects developed
in support of the national youth march for
integrated schools held in washington dc in
april 1959. the boys in youth for service know
that integration is not just the struggle of
american negroes for equality but it's linked
with the fight against discrimination
of all newly arrived minority groups
a hundred years ago the irish made up less than
one-third of the population of new york but they
were charged with over two-thirds of the arrests
there were newcomers then today the puerto ricans
the mexicans the pacific and oriental peoples of
the newcomer the youth service council raised the
money to send a delegate to washington the only
one sent by a san francisco youth organization and
he carried petitions gathered by many other
groups as well with over 6 000 signatures
and still in america some people are treated
like newcomers in their own native country
we call them indians this is the laytonville
rancheria of the pomo indian tribe in the
redwood forests 100 miles north of
san francisco one of the largest
youth for service projects was the building of
a bridge across a riverbed on this reservation
to give the indians access to a large section of
their land previously cut off during the rainy
season
um
do
so
a lot of people get confused about this youth
for service thing they tend to lump people into
categories or groups there are people who think
of youth for service as a youth serving agency
purely in terms of juvenile delinquency
prevention well if it works that way that's fine
but that's not our primary focus
that's not what we're here for
accepting individuals that's what makes
the whole thing meaningful when it comes
right down to it we have no political acts to
grind no religious acts to grind no social acts
or anything except that we are trying to
reconcile differences between people and that's
what this whole project is about reconciling
differences as well as doing something useful
we have a choice in dealing with these boys of
continuing the old community policy of suspicion
surveillance rejection and with the usual results
or we can take a new look at them and our own
attitudes and start to assume our just obligation
as citizens in helping them achieve recognition
and responsibility in the community youth for
service offers one way to work toward this end
well the bridge is built youth for service nobody
least of all the friends thinks this program is
a cure oil for anything if it does mean something
it'll be what the boys make it mean with our help
you